[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 débat alors que la loi sur
la programmation pluriannuelle de
l'énergie a été reportée par le
gouvernement le niveau de dioxyde de
carbone dans l'atmosphère n'a jamais été
aussi haut pourtant la france entend
diviser par six les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre face à cette urgence
climatique l'énergie nucléaire est
annoncé comme une solution pour certains
urgence climatique l'énergie nucléaire
était la solution c'est le débat du jour
et pour en parler j'accueille autour de
cette table jean louis tison bonsoir on
sort vous l'êtes président de la seine
yvelines val d'oise alors ce fan c'est
la société française d'énergie nucléaire
quelques mots sur cette association
puisque c'est une association
notre association regroupe trois mille
six cents adhérents
c'est une association qui s'intéresse à
tout ce qui touche au nucléaire que ce
soit l'énergie nucléaire ou le nucléaire
médical mais une mission d'information
j'imagine socialement de la formation
alors face avoue frédéric vincent
bonsoir elle vous êtes ingénieur docteur
en physique est également membre de
l'association alternative à versailles
même question quelques mois sur votre
association
alors alternatiba fait la promotion des
alternatives face au dérèglement
climatique l'épuisement des ressources
naturelles et les inégalités qui lui qui
augmente alors merci en tout cas à tous
les deux d'être présent ce soir là juste
pour commencer nous allons voir une
petite animation sur la répartition de
la production d'électricité en france en
2018 alors on peut voir que le nucléaire
représente plus de 71 % 12 4% pour
l'hydraulique encore 5,1 pour cent pour
l'éolien frédéric vincent comme tourne
vers vous votre avis sur cette
répartition la production d'énergie en
france abbas est une spécificité bien
française en fête
qui résulte d'un choix historique avec
le bas qui a été fait pendant le choc
pétrolier enfin la france a décidé bon
on aurait une certaine indépendance donc
on a développé le nucléaire moi ce que
je pense que je trouve intéressant c'est
que ça a diminué avant de tepito à 75%
de mémoire donc là nucléaire baisse
c'est plutôt encourageant ça va bayer
une tendance à jeudi on ne peut pas
passer à faire sortir du nucléaire enfin
moi ce dont je parle c'est le scénario
négawatt qui parle de la sortie du
nucléaire et des énergies fossiles d'ici
donc le nucléaire il est là pour au
moins de 30 ans il faut faire la leçon
ne change pas un système c'est un
paquebot en fait le la france le système
énergétique français c'est une inertie
donc moi ce que je trouve intéressant
c'est que les énergies renouvelables se
développent
voilà justement dans quelques minutes
jean l'utilisons pourquoi énergie et
nucléaire continue à être privilégié
pour justement lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique c'est ce que
disent certaines personnes pour écouter
ce qui se passe c'est que l'énergie
nucléaire de génère pas de co2 donc le
nucléaire lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique
la grande urgence du moment c'est pas de
changer de système
c'est de s'occuper du réchauffement
climatique
les tendances sont très lourdes avec une
augmentation de température et le
nucléaire dans tous les domaines de
génère aucun co2 donc le nucléaire
contribue à la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
c'est son rôle essentiel aujourd'hui il
faut surtout maintenir une énergie
électrique totalement décarbonés il ya
encore quelques pourcentages l'énergie
qu'ils ne sont pas propres en france
mais l'essentiel grâce au nucléaire et
déjà décarbonés il faut maintenir cette
solution dans l'urgence climatique
évidemment est un sujet qui concerne
tout le monde nous sommes allés
justement la rencontre est des yvelinois
il nous leur avons demandé si pour eux
il était possible de se passer de
l'énergie nucléaire
on écoute la réponse
le pourcentage de l'énergie renouvelable
dans le réseau sar est très très faible
pour moi le nucléaire est encore
indispensable voudrais vraiment que les
politiques qui s'impliquent beaucoup là
dessus pour pour qu'on puisse avoir une
vraie transition peut certes y ait un
danger pour l'environnement esterra mais
en tout cas pour l'instant je ne pense
pas qu'on puisse se passer complètement
du nucléaire on peut réduire mais pas
s'en passer et panneaux cela ils sont
pas recyclables après du coup quand ils
sont
enfin une vision on spolie m donc même
si c'est économique écologique a mis
dans un sac à main un impact sur
l'écologie moi j'avais vécu beaucoup en
espagne
bonne semaine et les hélices là les
éoliennes y en a beaucoup plus qui sait
rien et il semblerait qu'en espagne sont
beaucoup plus autonome à ce niveau là
mais en france ça va venir aussi un
frédéric vincent une réaction par
rapport à ce qu'on vient d'entendre va
c'est intéressant ça montre comme
diversité des points de vue moi je
voudrais enfin je vous revenir sur ce
que disent les gens rient en fait tu
m'as tu as fait d'accord quand on dit
que le nucléaire est complètement
totalement décarbonée parce que déjà
fois les extraire l'uranium en fait en
plus d'uranium on en a plus on va te
sais on a dit et des mines au kazakhstan
en australie ou au canada dernière c'est
de mémoire
donc ya pas de tonneaux me
d'indépendance énergétique de la france
ensuite les panneaux solaires qui sont
pas recyclables d'accord mais les
déchets nucléaires et le sont pas non
plus justement j'allais revenir sur les
déchets nucléaires parce que donc oui ça
y met moins de gaz à effet de serre mais
j'ai tant que faisons nous des déchets
alors sa vie - sané mais pas de gaz à
effet de serre un kilowattheure
électrique nucléaire c'est génère autant
de co2 qu'un kilowattheure électrique
éolienne ou c'est exactement 2 quand on
fait tourner une éolienne
on ferme une centrale nucléaire donc
l'énergie éolienne ne contribue en rien
au réchauffement climatique
donc ça c'est important de le noter ceux
qui crient au voeu de l'énergie
renouvelable
ça ne modifie en rien la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique c'est un
transfert
on passe de l'es22 du nucléaire à
l'éolien ou l'éolien au nucléaire
suivant qu'il ya du vent mais au niveau
du bilan carbone parce que c'est le
bilan carbone qui compte
il n'y a aucun impact dont privilégions
une industrie nationale des emplois de
120 mille emplois en france
en ligne directe un coût économique
intéressant parce que le kilowattheure
français nucléaire est facturé à un prix
tout à fait raisonnables le ménage
français paye son électricité à peu près
70 pour cent de moins que le ménage
allemand l'industrie française a accès à
l'électricité bon marché
ça renforce sa compétitivité donc ce
sont des atouts extrêmement important il
ya un point que je voudrais signaler
également sur les l'éolien et le
nucléaire c'est que au débat national on
a beaucoup parlé de de pouvoir d'achat
dont je vous le dis le nucléaire et
contribue les taxes l'énergie
éoliennes actuellement reçu l'équivalent
de 100 milliards d' euros de subventions
dans les dix dernières années pour un
bilan carbone
un bilan vis-à-vis de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
totalement nue puisque lorsque on fait
tourner une éolienne
on arrive une centrale nucléaire alors
sur les déchets vous m'avez interrogé
sur sur les déchets les déchets comme
toute industrie l'énergie nucléaire en
génère en france une particularité
importante c'est que nous avons un
inventaire extrêmement complet
extrêmement exhaustif de tous les
déchets radioactifs et de toutes les
matières radioactives qui lie à sur le
territoire et non seulement il y à un
inventaire son inventaire national
il y a aussi les filières d'évacuation
de ces déchets qui sont identifiés pour
chaque type de déchets donc actuellement
les déchets nucléaires les déchets
radioactifs nous avons 90 % des déchets
qui sont générés sur le sol français qui
ont une situation de stockage
opérationnels ils sont stockés dans des
lieux sûrs dans l'aube essentiellement
pour 90 % des volumes et pour les
quelques pourcents de volume pour lequel
on n'a pas encore de solution
opérationnelle
il y a le projet
6 géo de stockage en profondeur alors
beaucoup de choses à dire
alors gens lui disaient qu'ils avaient
on remplace l'éolien enfin l'unique
l'air par des liens alors derrière tout
ça et aussi c'est pas juste des
renouvelables à sa fin la transition
c'est qu'ils écologique c'est aussi
d'assaut vrille et et d'efficacité et la
sobriété c'est ben c'est un changement
de les usages si j'ai froid je vais
mettre un pull plutôt que de monter à
cheval
c'est plus un changement de comportement
d'abord un changement de comportement
ensuite l'efficacité faire isoler les
bâtiments pour réduire le coût du
chauffage qui est beaucoup électrique en
france notamment à cause du nucléaire et
les énergies renouvelables
donc en fait c'est les trois volets du
scénario négawatt sobriété efficacité
énergies renouvelables d'abord de
sobriété en fait on n'y arrivera pas
s'il ya pas de sobriété et la sobriété
c'est plus parce que ça nous permet
d'élargir un petit peu au liban s'est
arrêté de prendre l'avion pour ses
loisirs
donc voilà il ya vraiment des sujets là
dessus parce que on parle du nucléaire
de l'éolien mais c'est électricité mais
il est resté dans le monde sait à peu
près 20% de l'énergie quand le reste
c'est du pétrole du charbon
est-ce que selon vous les énergies
renouvelables sol peuvent suffire non
c'est d'abord des changements de
comportement c'est d'abord la sobriété
et puis ensuite d'efficacité donc isoler
les bâtiments pour moi c'est un énorme
sujet enfin en france en fait qu'il ya
plein de passoires thermiques et en fait
c'est la double peine pour les personnes
qui doivent payer plus cher leur marche
chauffages et puis derrière c'est c'est
beaucoup trop d'énergie qui dépensait
quoi que ce soit du nucléaire les
audiences et de l'énergie explique en
saison vous parliez d'argent tout à
l'heure alors en france il ya dix-neuf
centrales nucléaires dont il y en a pas
dans les yvelines ya 58 réacteurs
nucléaires quand on parle de centrales
nucléaires évidemment ne peut pas
s'empêcher de faire le lien avec les
accidents qui ont lieu à fukushima ou à
tchernobyl du coup pour la maintenance
ça coûte de l'argent finalement de la
maintenance de ses centrales nucléaires
le coup le coût de fabrication du
kilowattheure nucléaire il incorpore
effectivement toutes les dimensions la
sûreté de l'approvisionnement en
combustible l'exploitation la
maintenance et ce qui compte c'est le
coût total du kilowattheure est le coût
du total du kilowattheure il est
compétitif
il est compétitif et il est un niveau à
tout à fait acceptable en ce qui
concerne les les accidents il ya eu
effectivement des accidents dits
nucléaire je dirais vous avez mentionné
fukushima fukushima c'est d'abord un
tremblement de terre c'est une vague de
tsunami qui a fait 18 mille décès cdc là
ne sont pas des décès liés au nucléaire
ce qui s'est passé c'est que la centrale
a été effectivement submergé bon en
france malheureusement on n'est pas
soumis à des à des tsunamis nous avons
une autorité de sûreté nucléaire
totalement indépendant depuis
deux huiles depuis 2006 depuis fukushima
un grand programme de d'amélioration de
la sûreté de la sécurité à 2 a été mis
en oeuvre depuis depuis 2011
ça coûte de l'argent c'est le programme
de grand carénage
mais ça reste de inclus dans une dans
une enveloppe globale auxquels le pays
peut faire face lorsque le nucléaire est
compétitif en termes d'énergie propre
parce qu'il faut pas comparer le
nucléaire bien sûr nous charbon et au
gaz qui sont des énergies nom propre il
faut pas le comparer non plus aux coûts
d'une énergie comme l'éolien ou le
solaire qui ne génère pas de la
puissance électrique quand on en a
besoin
alors jean luc mélenchon juste obligé de
vous arrêter parce que malheureusement
le temps file on arrive à la fin de
cette émission va juste conclure 30
secondes chacun
l'énergie nucléaire est elle une réponse
une solution réchauffement planétaire
non bah il faut en sortir il ya des
solutions il ya des solutions avec le
stockage d'énergie nucléaire en fait le
coût de construction ne fait
qu'augmenter n'y a pas d'économies
d'échelle en fait c'était y'a une étude
indépendante fin par un chercheur qui a
été publié dans un comité de lecture où
on voit très bien qu'il ya ça fait
qu'augmenter en fait et on parlait des
finances mais le problème c'est que
comme les finances des acteurs du
nucléaire edf areva qui s'appelleront
morano maintenant sont pas très
sène a priori et puis à une certaine
opacité quoi donc puis après peut-être
falloir accepter aussi payer un peu plus
l'électricité en utilisant 20 secondes
pour conclure blé goudé le nucléaire
contribue la solution ce n'est pas la
solution et contribuer à la solution
l'urgence du moment c'est pas de sortir
du nucléaire c'est de lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique et le nucléaire
conquis prendre toute sa part c'est une
industrie nationale
c'est une industrie maîtriser ses 220
mille emplois en france et il n'y a
aucune raison d'arrêter
merci en tout cas tous les deux d'avoir
été présent ce soir voilà c'est la fin
de cette émission là merci à tous de
l'air de l'avoir suivi à mercredi
prochain
[Musique]